[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name
is caleb denby and tonight i have some
very exciting games
from the magnus carlson invitational
that just wrapped up that's the 2021
among this carlson invitational not the
one that took place
on the tail end of 2020. um and the
reason
why i wanted to go over some of these
games is because
there were some really exciting
situations in the tournament
uh and all of these knockout matches you
see these players getting backed into
must-win situations
and i think some of the most interesting
chess games from the tournament
sort of arose because of those must-win
situations it's really interesting to
see
what these players think will give them
the best chances of winning the game
as opposed to the the more safe style of
play that we're sort of
growing accustomed to at the top level
so to start with i want to take it back
to the semi-finals between jan
napomniashi
and magnus carlson so magnus actually
got off to a slow start in the semifinal
match
and had to win no fewer than two games
in a row
to force a tie break and this is game
one of two
that he absolutely had to win in order
to stay
in the match so neon had the white
pieces here we see on choosing e4
magnus goes for the sicilian we get
knight f3
e6 d4 take
take and now uh queen b6
so this is sort of a very offbeat line
in the sicilian uh and we're gonna see
that the way magnus plays it is actually
even more offbeat
than uh you might be expecting so the
early queen b6
it's a little bit strange it does have
the bonus of
uh not being queen c7 so knight b5
doesn't really
come with any kind of tempo the queen is
also helping to control
d6 so knight b5 is sort of being
lessened with the move queen v6 and of
course it's also applying pressure on
this diagonal
and this file so as such after the move
knight c3 by white just normal
development
you would expect to see something like
bishop c5 piling up on this diagonal and
of white response
maybe black gets a little bit crazy and
goes in for some random
queen takes b to idea trying to win
material right off the bat
but magnus actually just plays the move
a6 here
and after the move a3 magnus plays queen
to c7
now uh those of you less familiar with
the sicilian
or maybe even more familiar than me uh
this all
seems you know kind of reasonable right
you know we we brought the queen out
uh we maybe prevented bishop e3 for a
while and we're threatening to capture
this pawn
once white plays a3 this pawn is no
longer capturable
so we might as well play queen back to
c7 but to my eyes this does look very
strange because
black can just play a6 here and after
something like knight c3
go queen c7 and i don't think that um
white playing a3 is of any real benefit
to black and by the way this is just
the the mainline con sicilian this is
very very
very very common just mainline con
sicilian
and like sometimes white even plays a3
here so magnus is just getting a normal
con
down a full tempo uh which goes to show
you that these top-level players
don't care so much about their their
openings um
in these rapid matches at least i'm sure
over the board uh
in a classical time control magnus would
be a lot less likely to play something
like this
where he's playing with the black pieces
and also just down to full tempo once
once again for reference there
if i can pull it up this is the position
they had in the game with white to move
and this is a normal position in the con
sicilian with black to move so
just strictly losing a full tempo for no
reason uh kind of strange
by magnus but we'll see that that's not
really what counts in this game uh yan
continues that now with g3
of course yan only needs a draw in over
two games
in order to end the match here so g3
bishop g2 is a relatively safe way
to approach these positions you defend
your e4 pawn
you keep an eye on the d5 square and
you keep your king relatively safe so we
get uh g3 knight f6 bishop g2
knight c6 castles by white and now h5
by black magnus of course just
introducing some ideas of some kind of
attack on the h-file
making use of the coordination here
between the queen and the rook which
might not be obvious
at first knight takes c6 by yan
is simplifying things a little bit but
in a sense helping to build black's
center with control over the d5 square
and then after bishop f4 i want to give
the chat room
a little bit to think about what black's
plan
in this position is going to be and that
is the big idea
i want to talk about with pretty much
all of our games tonight
finding a winning plan in some really
complex
positions so chat what do we do about
this threat first of all
and secondly how does that affect our
plan moving forward
it's a weird timing off sicilian but
black should be fine
yeah so i'm a little bit out of my depth
on how all these different sicilians
transpose into each other
but this one i'm pretty sure is just a
con sicilian down a full tempo for no
reason
now i don't think a3 is the most testing
variation of the khan sicilian
but still probably a move white is
not unhappy to have included
bishop d3 so i'm assuming you mean
bishop d6 riley unfortunately
that square is attacked twice disaster
but you are correct in thinking maybe
that if we move the queen out of the way
then uh white will have some ideas of
occupying this square maybe even just e5
and going for for some kind of knight e4
d6
so in a sense black is forced to uh to
play the move
now pawn to e5 here and now after black
plays bishop g5
or sorry after white plays bishop g5 the
the point i want to get across here
is how difficult of a position this is
for black
at first glance it might not seem that
bad we haven't really given up too much
you know in fact we even have maintained
control over d5 there's never going to
be any knight d5 stuff
thanks to this capture by white but the
real difficulty comes when you start
thinking
well okay what is my plan and you might
say well you just develop your pieces
and castle i feel like bishop e7 and
kingside castles would be
what a lot of players play here but then
one once you
you know achieve that what's next are
you really playing for d5
in this position because once you play
d5 this bishop is going to open up
and all of white's pieces are very well
placed to prepare with an opening in the
center
white has this half open d file already
applying a lot of pressure in the
position
and that's what i want to talk about
here these positions where
the pawn structure seems very very fluid
but there's actually not really
a feasible plan using the pawns
that's where magnus carlsen really
excelled
in these two must-win games he didn't
really have any sorts of ideas but the
pawns no clear pawn break
that he was playing for but he manages
to just generate threats and generate
ideas with the pieces
so that's right tonight we're all
talking about peace play
so first and foremost i don't know if
you actually thought white was going to
take on f6 but apparently everybody in
this game
agreed that it was a big joke so uh
black plays bishop c5
and is not super worried about bishop f6
g takes f6
why isn't he super worried because
magnus is building a little bit of a
shelter
in the center of the board here in fact
after queen f3 could even expect to see
something like king e7
and with so many pawns in the center
magnus is going to
not be unhappy calling this place his
home for his king
um also this bishop is a pretty
worthwhile piece because once you take
on g
take on f6 you're going to have a
difficult time combating this bishop on
these dark squares
so bishop c5 uh jan plays queen f3
pretending to threaten bishop takes f6
of course it's still a joke
so magnus plays d6 why is it still a
joke now it looks like it wins a pawn
but we actually do have a nice little
inner meso here
before we recapture and then again it's
it's going to be a very similar story
so yan plays the move h3 instead sort of
renewing this threat
and now magnus finally says okay i will
move my knight out of the way we get
rook a to d1 now
and this is uh where magnus starts
playing
like you know super genius world
champion magnus carlson
so once again i would find this position
to be sort of insanely difficult
yet magnus somehow is finding all of
these correct moves
in a position where you have kind of
as many options as as you can count
right like like any move here is
probably going to be fine but to find
something constructive to do
is no easy task so let's see if we can
find a constructive plan and i'll give
you a hint
in these positions where you're really
just playing with the pieces
most of your plans should be to find
some way
to improve your pieces so how do we
improve the pieces here
what's our plan to improve the pieces
tarman says i don't want a castle we're
attacking with the a truck
um i think you may be more ambitious
than me if you think
this rook is being involved in some sort
of major attack on the king site here
it's going to be really difficult
to bring any other pieces into this
attack aside from this rook and you
could argue this bishop is involved as
well
and yeah the chat room as expected is
coming up with about
uh 12 different ideas because it's the
kind of position where there really are
just 12 different ideas
i do like what magnus did in the game
the the best and somebody in the chat
did say it chess knowledge said it and
it's this move knight to f8
magnus uh kind of just understands how
to coordinate the pieces here
for example it doesn't make a lot of
sense to play a move like bishop b7
you know a lot of players might want to
get the bishop off the back rank here
but this bishop doesn't really do
anything on b7 again
we're not really playing for d5 this
isn't really
that that desirable of a pawn break in
this position where white is just so
much better prepared to handle the
opening of things so we just want to
improve our pieces so knight f8
and magnus is just going to bring this
knight to e6 eject this bishop and play
for some control over d4
just keeping things very calm not
rushing at all
not worried about being in a must-win
situation just taking it one move at a
time
and improving the pieces now we see jan
play knight a4
getting a little bit antsy to trade off
some pieces perhaps
also of course preparing some idea like
c3
if necessary to control the d4 square
magnus just continues now with knight e6
we get bishop e3 and magnus simply
captures
on e3 now the computer says something
like knight d4
is a good idea and i suppose the point
is this queen is trapped
and you are obliged to capture and it
liked having this powerful dark squared
bishop sort of the same idea that we saw
with bishop takes f6 never being played
because the dark squared bishop is going
to be a good piece controlling this
important diagonal instead though magnus
just takes off the dark squared bishops
with bishop e3
we get queen e3 and now h4 opening up
this h file for the rook so so far we've
seen magnus improve the knight
and now with h4 magnus is simply
improving the rook
as well jan finds some tactical ideas
though with knight b6
we get rook to b8 and now knight c4
and this is the the trouble with having
such a fluid pawn center against such a
strong player
while magnus was busy improving the rook
with h5 h4
and improving the knight with knight d7
to f8 to e6
yan was realizing hey yeah your pawn
center is great for controlling all
these super important squares
but at the same time you know there are
some weaknesses here
and there's simply no good way to defend
this pawn on d6
so of course magnus doesn't defend it
just castles
castles king side and relies on the
counter play coming from
the half open b file so if you don't
take this
pawn now you might never get the chance
to for example if you play
i don't know it's hard to come up with a
passing move something like king h2
magnus can play something like knight d4
and
block off the rook's access here and
then the tactics sort of continue here
magnus is going to be able to take off
the attacking knight in order to save
this pawn
while maintaining some pressure here so
it goes to show you
how in such a flexible position every
move
really counts here magnus is sort of
saving this pawn by a tempo
in these variations whereas if we had
played
one slightly slower move for example
here if we had just taken the time to
play something like bishop a7
and we went down the exact same
variation
all of a sudden you know
you're sort of left without a without a
chance here like you can castle
but uh now all these variations are just
going to be a lot better for example
even if you play something
like b3 just to defend your your pawn on
b
uh your pawn on b2 okay b3 is not a very
good move but for example
now knight takes d6 is just up a clean
tempo
over what we had seen before and it's
going to be a very important tempo
in the game so goes to show you how
every move counts even in position
even in positions like this where it's
really just about peace play you have to
be able
to generate meaningful threats and
meaningful ideas
or else your opponent will do so first
that's the lesson to take away here so
knight f8 knight a4
and we get this position with knight b6
and castles
uh now in the game jan couldn't find
anything better than taking on d6
so that is what yon went for we see the
inner meso hg3 fg3
and now magnus simply captures on b2
with queen c3 to follow okay
so now the rook's attacked the pawns
attacked things are starting to look a
little bit awkward
but magnus is keeping it together for
the moment with queen b8
now if you were to try capturing on e5
magnus is going to continue capturing
pawns as well with rook takes c2 so
that's why magnus plays
queen b8 rather than something like
retreating the rook
because then queen e5 might just be a
good idea so queen b8
and i want everybody to look at this
position
and look at how well the white pieces
are coordinated together
right yan sort of has everything figured
out this queen
is seemingly perfectly placed defending
the two weaknesses
attacking a weakness in black's camp the
knight is cemented on the sixth rank
supported by the rook
this rook is on a half open file and
okay maybe you can argue the bishop
isn't as good as it could be but it's
also keeping an eye on some really
important weaknesses meanwhile black's
position is starting to look a little
bit haphazard like this pawn is hanging
this pawn is hanging this bishop only
has like two legal moves
it's not really doing a whole lot this
rook is purely defensive
against of course the well-coordinated
attack by the white pieces
and everything is starting to feel a
little a little bit loose right this
queen's defending the rook
also defending the bishop you know the
rook is defending the bishop the rook is
also defending f7
everything's sort of hanging by a thread
and multiple things just outright
hanging
in this position so for the moment you
know if i didn't know any better i would
say white should have some advantage
and it turns out that this precarious
positioning of black's pieces
is sort of good enough to hold
everything together but not really do
do more than that for the moment but
over the next few moves magnus sort of
miraculously turns this around against
you know super strong player jan
napomnishi
and as few as like five moves later it's
just a complete reversal
white's pieces are entirely misplaced
and black's pieces suddenly make
a great deal of sense so so let's see
how that happens um for the moment
like i said queen e5 means work takes c2
and queen takes c6 would also be a
mistake
in light of rook b6 when this knight is
actually going to die
unfortunately so can't take any of the
free pawns here
instead jan just plays knight f5 perhaps
preparing
some kind of threat like queen to c6
uh that being said magnus realized
that there was actually no real threat
here and plays the move
rook b5 well i guess rook b5 is also
responding to the threat but perhaps not
as passively as jan might have liked
now of course if you take on c6 you're
just going to get bent
by a knight d4 and some activity by
black and if you play the more natural
move knight e7
check magnus plays king h7 and this
actually happens in the game
and now again there's just simply not
much benefit to taking this pawn on c6
if you take like this
you're gonna get met with queen b6 check
and rook c5
and again the knight will fall and if
you take with the queen
then again knight d4 is one idea but
actually queen a7 check is just a a
simple fork
so no good way to capture this pawn and
because of that
yan improves the king with king h2 now
of course these checking ideas aren't in
the position and knight takes c6 is a
perfectly legitimate threat so we get
queen c7 to defend
um now of course the knight's attacked
and if you take the bricks c5
just to highlight so jan plays the
knight back to f5
now all of a sudden we get rook c5 queen
d2
rook d8 queen f2 and rook c3
and this is the position i want to
highlight now
where things have really started to uh
to turn around right we we had white's
pieces
placed sort of so perfectly well and now
after just two more moves
uh or one more full move actually a4
defending the pawn and knight d4
it's just a complete role reversal right
all of black's pieces are seemingly
working together now this rook now
occupies the square
that used to be such a good square for
the white queen now this rook
is occupying the third rank pressuring
the king pressuring c2
the knight just left into the game
pressuring the knight on f5 and
activating this bishop the queen is
doing a great defensive job
and supports the rook on d8 and the
weakness on e5
and seemingly out of nowhere
in five moves magnus carlsen has
improved all of his pieces
and somehow forced jan to make his
pieces worse right the queen is
significantly worse than f2 than it was
on c3 the knight on f5 is a bit too
loose to stay there anymore and the d
file is now contested you could argue
the king is safer
and the bishop is is just still hanging
out here on g2 not doing much so
really impressive stuff by magnus
carlson and it sort of comes out of
nowhere
and it comes from yan playing a bit too
quickly i think
um what do i mean by too quickly
not necessarily even on the clock but
trying to win the game sort of
immediately with tactical threats
instead
i think the way to play here is to just
improve your pieces slowly right no need
to go for these 97 complications if
they're not tactically winning anything
so moves like h2 here are good
rook f2 to d2 ideas like this are
perfectly fine
even something as simple as a4 and
bringing the rooks to both open files
all of these ideas
would have been good for white i think
but instead we see
jan getting a little bit carefree going
after some pawns
and with a few just a few tempe magnus
has completely taken over the position
um now is actually one of the last
chances for white to
actually stay in the game black is going
to be significantly better here after
the game continuation of knight takes d4
there
is actually one line that the engine
finds
to be a draw and it's one of those
engine perpetuals with knight takes g7
and actually rook takes d4 what's the
point
well the point is that you're going to
get checked forever and ever and ever
no way to escape if you try coming this
way of course then f7 falls
and it's a simple simple perpetual
everybody saw that coming
of course but jan missed it in the game
and took on d4 instead
so what happens now well magnus takes on
d4
and of course all this pressure on the f
file is nice you can take the f7 pawn
for free
that's so powerful but then you know c2
falls
a4 falls this bishop might fall with
pressure on the second rank
and you're gonna get kind of steamrolled
in that end game just just to show an
example line here
okay well actually you can't take f7 yet
if you were to take here first though
and then take f7 um number one that
pawn's hanging and number two
this is just quite simply a losing end
game right this d pawn is way too strong
the c pawn is also here to support as
well and this bishop is
still entirely out of the game um but
okay queen e2 played in the game
jan realizes he needs threats around
magnus's king uh or else
he's just going to lose uh and again i
can't stress
how crazy it is that in five moves
magnus goes from having these
discombobulated pieces to just sort of
steamrolling yawn
down the center of the board but that's
what we have here now magnus plays
bishop b6
just developing we do see this trait of
rooks on d4
and now a check and yan you know in
classic yan style is like
okay fine you might have improved all
your pieces and
taken over the center of the board but
i'm just going to check meet you and
none of that will matter
and believe it or not here there's only
one clean move here
that wins the game for magnus carlsen
it's actually minus four
according to stockfish 13 if uh
if magnus finds the right idea here and
i'll be impressed if anybody in the chat
can uh can find it
black to move here there's actually only
one really clean way to win there's
a few moves that keep the advantage a
little bit but uh
this move is minus four if you can find
it uh and the chat room is
mourning the scruff that i had i
i have shaved since the last class i
wouldn't
go as far as to call it a beard but
i don't think it's coming back no i was
just being a bit lazy i i don't think it
looked good to be honest but that's okay
and somehow nick wiese finds the right
idea with
c5 and this one is a little bit
mysterious to me
but at the end of the day it turns out
that white's pieces are hanging in this
sort of
awkward looking balance here where if
any
of these major pieces move to continue
the attack there's going to be pretty
severe repercussions so
first and foremost let's look at the
more natural moves right you know
to me you know pawns hanging that's
pretty natural
why not take the free pawn and of course
the reason is
now rook h4 comes into the game uh why
couldn't what pla
why couldn't white play h4 anyways after
c5
well now of course lyric on c3 is a
useful attacking piece as well
and queen takes g3 king g1 it turns out
that
uh black isn't getting checkmated at all
after king f8 and white definitely is
getting checkmated
after you know one or two more moves
plenty of ways for this rook to invade
and uh and that'll be the end of the
game
so c5 just sort of keeps this rook at
bay
now if we uh move the the queen
as white after c5 well now perhaps black
is able to play rook takes c2
because rook h4 isn't really coming with
a threat anymore
and that's why c5 is so powerful it's
just a very useful move
that is kind of preparing for the
oncoming end game where these pawns are
rolling up the board
and it highlights the fact that white
can't really improve
either of these pieces uh thanks to the
threats
around g3 and the threat to the c2 pawn
as well so c5
really crazy idea uh don't blame magnus
for not playing it in the game
with four minutes on the clock magnus
instead plays a little bit more human
move
queen e7 and why is this a human move
well because i don't think it actually
helps defend the black king
that much at all but as a human you feel
better the closer your queen is to your
king in situations like this i don't
know why it just makes you feel safer
and i am arguing to 115 people that
magnus played this move because it made
him feel safer not because he calculated
of course probably he had some idea and
that idea is f6 here
and using this queen to guard some of
these important squares
on the back rank uh so maybe not just
playing on feelings is magnus carlsen
but that's sort of how it looks um okay
e5
now by yan is a really nice find if
white isn't playing this move e5 here
white's definitely going to be in a lot
of trouble and it's pretty intuitive why
right this bishop has been out of the
game
since move seven and uh e5 is just the
way to to bring it into the attack
um yeah if white doesn't find this idea
it just
plays some random move like uh check for
example
queen g6 or something it turns out that
magnus is actually
getting away with it here playing king
e7
and there's simply no way to continue
this attack you can't really play
rook g8 if you play rook h7 here for
example
okay the queen's hanging you can't
increase the pressure to g7 anywhere you
can't get on the back rank
it's just a surprisingly sturdy fortress
by
the world champion it's going to take
quite quite a few turns
to organize another threat here so much
time in fact
that magnus would have plenty of time to
just capture on c2
in this position so instead of that jan
does find the nice idea e5
magnus of course takes the free pawn and
now
jan plays queen takes e5 as well
again just preparing bishop e4 so of
course now rook takes c2
is the natural idea pinning the the
bishop to the king
but at this point the advantage has
actually passed
for magnus he may have defended his king
adequately
but not really done much more than that
it's clear now that white again
has a lot of activity and that's the
back and forth that that comes from
these games
that are so centered around having the
more active pieces
it's really interesting to watch you
know how these players manage to seize
activity
seemingly out of nowhere by making just
a few concrete threats
uh okay now now that jan has you know
fixed his position he immediately ruins
it by playing rook to e4
what a dummy he thought bishops were
worth three and they were worth
capturing but instead um
you know in instead it turns out that
the d pawn is worth more than the bishop
here
uh surprisingly so rookie for winning a
piece
is just totally the wrong idea of course
what should white have done instead well
you can go back to making threats around
this king and playing for some kind of
perpetual
you can also play something like queen
e4 with the idea of stopping e3
d3 for the moment and of course
ideas of checking as well but rookie
four
now after d3 white is going to be in for
a difficult end game
white of course takes the free bishop we
trade off this piece
and now magnus plays d2 and yeah
turns out when a pun gets to the second
rank it can sometimes be worth more
than a bishop so of course you can't
play the natural-looking bishop to f3
because this move is check so you have
to find some other way to stop the pawn
and that other way is with rook to d6
now we get some not king f8 by magnus
carlsen
but instead c5 and now you know c5 a few
turns ago was super brilliant in the
best move
and in this situation it's actually a
blunder and it's
really kind of crazy to uh to understand
why
so magnus's idea in the game is very
intuitive you want to push the pawn to
c3
play rook c1 play you know d1 queen
right easy super easy to understand i
understand that
um also push the pawn to c3 play rook b2
and then play c2
rook takes pawn c1 also an acceptable
answer but
basically magnus's winning plan revolves
around getting this king
are getting this pawn to c3 however
white does have a fortress that can be
constructed here
to stop these pawns in their tracks and
it's pretty
incredible how this can actually be done
so let's take a look white plays g4
black plays c4 and white plays king g3
so
these look like very slow moves by white
but they're actually
entirely needed because you know
otherwise the second you move this
bishop
this move comes with checks so you have
to get this king off the second rank
somehow and that's all
jan is doing here with king g3 now after
c3
yan actually misses his chance to
construct the fortress so
chat see if you can find the drawing
idea here
for yon napomnishi
white to move and draw
ah and tristan in the chat room that's a
name i haven't seen in a while
probably because he didn't realize we
moved the road to 2000 to
tuesdays so yeah here we are been here
ever since we were on wednesdays
okay there's a couple ideas in the chat
bishop e4 bishop
f3 and they're not really getting to the
heart of the idea
so yeah it turns out the check is
actually correct here
but what is the point of the check
what's the purpose
where are you guys headed with this
bishop
where are you headed with the bishop
why does jan's last name sound like the
name for a flavor of ice cream
that's a question for yon interesting
story about yon's last name which i can
never pronounce correctly
um i do know more than yasser sarawan
who says
napomniach i can't even say it like he
does
um i'm pretty sure this chtch is like a
soft
sha of some kind but anyways
my friend who speaks some russian told
me that uh jan's last name
literally means no nothing it's
something like
no nothing or like remember nothing or
forget everything
something like that so interesting that
it became superstar chess player who
knows everything
okay bishop d5 and bishop b3 is the
correct idea that the chat room is
coming up with
and this is a rather you know surprising
it's a surprisingly resilient uh idea by
white here
rook b2 and it looks like you're sort of
getting busted but after bishop d1
it turns out that c2 is only good for a
draw
because we can give this bishop up for
one of those pawns
play king f3 to e3 and capture this pawn
uh peacefully and the game is of course
going to end in
a draw white has or black has plenty of
chances
to take a different pawn in exchange for
it
um you know even rick g3 here there's a
thousand different ways to draw the game
but bishop d5 to b3 only way to draw the
game
which brings us back to this position
with the pawn on c6
it turns out that black has a pretty
astounding idea
to win a tempo in this position and that
idea
is to play the move king f8 and you can
actually play king of seven but king f8
makes a bit more sense to me
and the point is this move actually wins
a tempo why does this win a tempo
well white is going to play the same
idea you have to get the king off the
second rank
and now after king to e7 if you're
counting we spent one tepo on king f8
which in the other line we had to spend
anyways due to bishop d5 check
now we're spending another tempo on king
e7 but we're not really losing a tempo
because the rook has to move and then of
course
the big idea is that we gain
one more attempt oh we'll start we can't
do this yet because the d1 queen you
have to play king g3
the big idea is we're actually gaining a
second tempo
because the rook had to move into the
path of the pawn and now
we play one of our pawn moves with tempo
so
really interesting uh end game idea to
to uh to force a win here it's not one
that is
super common and you know as far as i
know this is
a pretty unique idea forcing the rook to
come up
the board so that your pawn can gain a
tempo against it
fun stuff so now of course the idea
of sacking the bishop for the b for the
c pawn simply isn't going to work you
can
go here uh to stop the d-pawn
but uh it's not quite going to be enough
here
so who sees the idea now for black
to uh to finish it off and get a
substantial advantage
who sees the point
so c2 is one of the move orders you can
do it in
and the idea now is that after takes you
have rook f1 check
and you get the queen against the bishop
in the rook now is this winning i don't
want to talk about it okay we're not
going to talk about it
maybe but i don't want to talk about it
okay
the more fun way to do it is to sack
your rook first for absolutely no reason
at all
and then play c2 because um white has
nothing better than to take on d2
anyways
um but yeah fun fun stuff but magnus
misses it in the game pushes the pawn
first like a dummy
how could he not see the brilliant idea
but then
jan actually plays king h4 here missing
the fortress and now the win
is a bit more trivial we do see king f8
by magnus stepping out of the check
now after bishop f3 simply rook c1
and it's even worse than before because
rook f1
attacks this bishop and it's it's just
so sad
it's just so sad queen for a rook rather
than queen for rook and a bishop and
magnus
wins his first must-win game and wow i
am not so good at budgeting time i told
ben we would go over like four games
tonight
we're lucky if we get through two but
okay this was a
pretty deep game with a lot of ideas uh
really fun to see
how the world champion plays with the
pieces in a position where there's
seemingly no concrete plan just
definitive
improvement with concrete ideas and
concrete threats
and then eventually you know the
activity speaks for
for itself and magnus defeats yon in the
first
must-win game all right i'm going to
leave it up to you chatroom should we go
over magnus's next must-win game or
should we go
over yon's must-win game against anish
geary
in the finals in the finals
let's see i'm going to do the first one
i read in the chat i'm going to do the
first one i read
yawn but yawns in both games okay i'll
go over yon's must win game against
anish giri
um so of course it was all great fun to
look at these must win games from magnus
carlsen
um he actually won both of his must win
games
but then lost in the tie breaks to jan
so that's how we end up with anish giri
against jian
in the finals and jan was actually
behind on
the second day of the finals
and had to win just one must win game
not quite as exciting as magnus's two
must win games
but still pretty good so let's see how
he does it against anish here
we're going to take a look we have e4 c5
once again knight f3 knight c6
bishop b5 and anish the drawing master
knows that the way to draw with the
white pieces in the sicilian
is not by doing any of this crazy you
know con
transposition stuff you play bishop b5
you take the knight on c6 and now the
game is a draw now white can't lose
literally impossible to lose
uh unfortunately though you know anish
did lose this game
so this is the rossolimo of course why
do i say it's impossible to lose
uh with the rossolimo well it's actually
kind of a similar situation to what we
had in the game we just looked at
black is left with the two bishops but
due to the weaknesses in the pawn
structure
it's a very very difficult to come up
with a concrete plan
it's difficult to play for pawn breaks
when you have this kind of weakness in
the structure
and so what this does well it forces
black to play with the pieces and we saw
magnus did that very very
well in game one let's see how jan is
able to do it here
we get d3 by white uh 97 by yan
knight g6 uh now h4
trying to harass this knight a little
bit so h5 by black
um e5 now by anish geary taking some
extra space in the center clearing the
way for the knight
um d6 is challenging this central pawn
but of course now you know in classic
rosalina style the pawn structure for
black
seems to just be getting worse by the
minute okay
e takes d6 yawn's in no rush to
recapture this pawn it's not really
going anywhere
knight c4 by white bishop g4 tactically
defending the pawn
bishop g5 now f6 bishop back to d2
and finally bishop d6 queen e2
uh okay and once again we find ourselves
in this situation
where there's no clear plan for black
now the the upside as in the previous
case is there's not
a super clear pawn break you know you
know concrete plan
for white either in this case plan
meaning you know some kind of pawn break
you're hoping to achieve those are the
positions that i actually
prefer those positions where you have
some clear idea you know i'm playing the
carol khan
i want to play the move c5 easy enough
to understand
i'll position my pieces to play c5 or
like i'm playing against
i'm playing a king's indian defense my
idea is the pawn storm on the king's
side
or the pawn storm on the queen's side
you know none of that is really
going to be showing up in this position
right the c
pawns definitely aren't going anywhere
it's not like black is really going to
get e4 in any time
soon and for white i mean any pawn break
is only going to improve black's pawn
structure at this point so why would you
even attempt one so what this means is
again the players are going to have to
play
to improve their pieces so in the game
yan starts by bishop c7 and this is a
move i really want to highlight
to beginners i just taught a class last
week
on spotting tactics in your games and
you know the one thing i really wanted
to drill home with that class is that
the more loose pieces you have
the more tactical opportunities there
are going to be for your opponent
so jan spends a full tempo taking this
bishop on
from this square where it's attacked by
the knight to a square where it's just
not attacked at all
you know there was no tactic threatened
i'm fairly certain white was not making
a threat
against this bishop on d6 but yan still
just is like yeah
why not have my piece on a square where
it's not attacked and that's something i
strongly encourage
beginners around the world to do as well
by the way black still has a lot of
pieces undefended and you might be
thinking queen e4
is a tactic and it almost is but
thankfully 97 saves the day
so it goes to show you just tactics
appear when you leave pieces undefended
which is why yon is starting
to uh improve the pieces in that manner
we get queen side castles by anish and
king side castles by yon now
king b1 always a good idea when you well
almost always a good idea when you queen
side castle
just shore up your your defense of the
king here
rook b8 yawn playing very uh cleanly
just putting the rook on a half open
file in front of the king
we get rook d to g1 and this is the
start of some uh
some weirdness now by anish geary i'm
gonna climb a niche is
sort of going for some sort of king side
attack
but again you know it's not super clear
what the specifics of this attack are is
white playing trying to play g4
yeah maybe but at the same time the the
f4 square is going to be a hole
and you have a long way to go before
you're defending the g4 square
or before you're defending the square
enough to to push upon to it
so this is where i think uh yan starts
to uh to take control of the game a
little bit yan now
jumps in with knight to f4 we get bishop
takes and pawn takes
and now jan has two bishops in the worst
pawn structure
anyone has ever seen in their lives
so how does yan manage such a bad pawn
structure
well again one huge downside to it is
that
you don't really have any clean pawn
break ideas any clean plans in the
position
so you're forced to play with the pieces
the other downside
is that if you are not more active than
your opponent you definitely have more
weaknesses than your opponent all of
these pawns
i would consider to be weaknesses in the
long run
so jan definitely needs to get some sort
of advantage in activity let's see how
he does it
anish now brings this rook back to e1
perhaps highlighting that rook g1
was maybe not the greatest idea i
honestly didn't understand it all that
much
but okay queen d5 now by jan and you do
see that he does have some compensation
for the terrible pawns right uh
black is somehow someway controlling
three of the central squares despite
having
zero central pawns queen back to d1 now
and rookie eight so the only open file
is contested
the queen is well active and centralized
and
the bishop on g4 is applying some
pressure to the position
now we get b3 by white king f7 not even
taking time out of his day
to improve his king here uh a4 now by
uh by white and yan just brings the
second rook into the center
king a2 and now jan takes improving the
king to a little bit of a
little bit of an extreme here with king
f7 to uh to g6 but
this is something i want to highlight
here is you know when
there's no concrete you know break
concrete idea
with the pawns that you can play for you
get these weird-looking games
where there's a billion pieces on the
board and napomnishi is playing king f7
king g6
so this is what it looks like at the top
level
when there's no clear plan they play for
every
bit of improvement they can with the
pieces in yon's case
he's bringing the king up the board
preparing for god only knows what
uh but that's the idea when there's no
plan you improve your pieces
rick hg1 now by anish and perhaps
this is the rook that should have gone
there in the first place
now jan plays king h6 and at this point
i think he's just being funny
um rook back to h1 is kind of chasing
this king around a little bit
uh at this point of course yan is in a
must-win situation
so niche is probably hoping for some
kind of repetition here
now though jan continues the game with
queen f7
we get king back to b1 and now bishop e6
so
all of a sudden jan has engaged in some
kind of major repositioning of the
pieces
we get knight f to d2 enyon decides that
this bishop is better placed than the
queen
on this nice d5 outpost challenging the
king's side pawns
uh rook back to g1 is the idea and now
queen g6 and we see this sort of funny
transposition of the queen and the
bishop the queen goes to the g file
and the bishop goes to the square that
the queen wants occupied
we get the trade on e8 the trade on e8
and now
f3 and it turns out that f3
is a pretty critical mistake in the game
so
who knows why f3 is a mistake here
who knows
what's so bad about f3
and then grey wolf has a point about the
bishop c7 move earlier in the game that
i might want to return to we'll see
nick is also saying d5 97 knight g6
this comment may be too old for me to
respond to i'm not sure i remember
the position
hole on f2 backwards g pawn queen g3 so
yeah
the big point here isn't that the pawn
is backwards f3
is actually played with the express idea
of defending the g
pawn a bit more thoroughly but now the
problem of course is that
this is going to be a hole in the
position
that anish giri is going to have to deal
with and now
i want to i might be giving anish a lot
of credit here but i think he had a
pretty deep
idea to uh to stop queen g3 or at least
make sure it wasn't
um so harmful and we actually see this
idea
potentially appear in the game although
there's obviously going to be a problem
with it
so first and foremost why don't we play
queen g3 right away
well the answer is that knight e4 is
actually going to be a good idea and
don't even think about taking this guy
because now your queen has no squares to
go to
zero squares those are all defended just
trust me don't check for yourself
and so now of course this knight can be
captured but at the end of the day
queen takes h4 is still going to be a
little bit lackluster in light of the
newly open d
file when white is actually now probably
winning because
you know this is a fork two pieces are
attacked at the same time how dare you
have loose pieces yawn
so instead yan is super smart he says
wait knight e4 is a problem what if i
just make it
so that's not a problem anymore and he
plays the move f5 which is correct
and now anisha's deep idea to make sure
that queen g3 is not a problem springs
into action here
queen to f1 so who
understands queen to f1 well of course
now
after queen to g3 uh anish
plays rook to h1 and i like to imagine
anish was feeling pretty clever
at this moment because if you're not
careful
you know rook h3 is potentially going to
uh
evict your queen and anisha is going to
start to take over the game once again
um now obviously there's an immediate
problem with that being rook
to e1 but we'll see in a few moments
that this problem is going
to go away so what should yon be doing
now
for the moment it looks like he's
starting to take over the game
purely with the pieces alone but how do
you continue
yevan would totally lose your queen
there and uh we'll see that yan may be
in a similar boat pretty soon
except jan might be losing his queen uh
on purpose
remains to be seen i don't know
so how do you continue here
just knowledge says bishop d8 which is
so bad that jan played it in the game
that's how bad it is okay um
so yeah bishop d8 is fine it's what it's
what was played in the game it's
uh not entirely the most accurate but it
is uh sort of the right idea you just
add another attacker
to this pawn on h4 and the threats start
to compound
for uh for black it turns out though
that white does have a pretty nice
response in the form of knight d6
when all of a sudden all your things are
hanging and you have to be very very
careful
that things don't go quite badly so for
example if rookie
five all of a sudden now you're dealing
with d4
and knight two to c4 and things are
getting a little bit too complex for me
right you know too many things are
hanging and this is what you get yawn
this is what you get
when you make loose pieces and leave
yourself open for common tactical ideas
like night forks against your king and
queen
this is why you should play solidly make
sure your pieces are defended play
something like rook e6
defend your loose squares before
rerouting
the bishop so rookie six is actually the
best here just stopping knight d6
and then uh only after rookie six
playing bishop d8
so bishop d8 knight d6 played in the
game now it does turn out rookie five
is the best idea here to keep this rook
h3 idea at bay
with the threat of rookie one check
instead jan plays rook f8
so now you know anish has solved the
problem of his rookie
uh his has solved his ricky one problem
and
uh can go about playing uh rook h3
with you know no qualms
right chat room everyone agrees everyone
agrees
well the rook h3 here it turns out is uh
not very good um black black is just
going to uh play queen back to g6
and while you did solve the problem of
the h4 pawn for the moment
your your pieces are still pretty loose
which is why niche plays knight 2
to c4 first allowing bishop
takes h4 and now after knight e5
you might start to think that hey maybe
there are some real problems here
for jan and in fact
rook to d rook to f6 played in the game
and now anisha is getting a little bit
desperate
plays the move c4 hitting this bishop
get bishop back to g8
now knight b7 saving the knight rookie
six
and now finally rook h3
and uh you know anish is is of course
killing it here right
rook h3 attacking the queen so black to
move and win
black to move and win
oh and there's a question in the chat if
i make content anywhere and i do have a
youtube channel
but i wouldn't say i make content for it
i haven't uploaded in a few months now
but i'm hoping to start again so look me
up on youtube
if you guys are interested
what if he plays rock e6 then bishop d8
looks so strong
hey that's what i said except i said
rook instead of rock
that's okay so of course the winning
idea here
um is queen g5 saving the queen um
unfortunately it does turn out that this
does win as well but you know jan
is a showman so he plays rick takes e5
sacrificing the queen
and now of course bishop takes g3 and it
turns out that this queen is
entirely trapped no way to save it here
can't get off the back rank and if you
move the king off the back rank
then you just can't move the queen
anywhere
and so nishkiri resigns in the must-win
game for yan and so of course
yan was able to force the playoffs where
anish
beat him anyways and that's
unfortunately kind of the story of this
event
players coming through in their must-win
situations only to lose in the tie
breaks
now there was an idea i wanted to return
to earlier in this game
that great wolf brought up which is
why did black play the move bishop c7
great wolf thought it was perhaps
because knight takes d6
gets rid of the bishop pair for
gets rid of black's bishop pair which is
you know in a sense the compensation
for having such a bad punch structure i
don't know that i agree
i think that black could be perfectly
fine just castling here
and after takes takes not really be any
worse off
uh because he's missing this bishop in
fact it may even grant some extra
opportunities
in the form of a c4 break that otherwise
this knight on c4
would be preventing for example if you
were to castle here
i don't know about c4 immediately but
something like
queen e6 hitting this guy and
c4 to follow and black is going to have
a lot more ideas
you might be on to something with the
bishop pair thing you know these gems do
love bishop pairs
but i honestly think it's about keeping
your pieces solid
keeping them away from the threat of
capture and ensuring that tactics don't
crop up
uh okay we've got just a few minutes
left i don't think
we have time to go over another game
but i do want to open up to any
questions in the chat room for me
on anything we covered today um it's
these were some pretty complicated games
the the point i want to get across here
is these gm's they really really excel
at the top level at these positions
where there's no definite
plan that i believe at least for me
personally
is the hardest part of chess these
positions where neither player really
has a plan
and you just have to somehow
miraculously you know coordinate the
pieces in just the right way
to make your opponent slip up so really
interesting stuff
to see how these top level guys are
navigating these positions
[Music]
would love to watch 1400 to 1800 lessons
from
me my teaching style is fantastic you
guys are too kind to me
in the youtube chat tonight two kinds
but uh yeah i do have some roger 2000s
actually where i analyze games from that
exact rating range
i'm not sure if i'm going to be able to
find them offhand and remember the
titles
but those earlier wrote to 2000s were
more
in that rating range how many moves are
intuitive and how much is calculated in
chess okay these are sort of general
questions
i'll answer one more and then i think
we're just gonna cut it here um so
in chess i think the role of intuition
in over the board games is generally
to be your idea generator that's where
you find your ideas you look to your
intuition be like
this move feels like it could be good
and then you hammer it home
with calculation you know you say i want
to play this move this move looks like
it should be good
and then the the way that you determine
if it's good or not
is by calculating out the specifics so
they they kind of go hand in hand
um with that in mind i want to thank you
all very much for watching tonight i had
a lot of fun
going over this uh tournament watching
some of it live
uh these chess 24 events the the whole
magnus carlson chess tour has been a lot
of fun
to watch hopefully you guys are enjoying
it as well
let me know what you want to see more of
do you want to see more of these
tournament coverages
in the comments below i'm always looking
for new ideas as i move into
you know having like 120 hours of chess
content online
new ideas always appreciated uh so once
again thank you all so much for watching
as always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
[Music]
you